- I have this song, "Piece by Piece,"
and I'm the writer.
- Yes.
And, (laughs)
and it was all about like, for me,
it was like I'd never really experienced
the loss of my father.
Like how it...
It never impacted me
until I became a parent.
'Cause then I knew what a parent should be
and what it felt like.
- Amen.
And I was like, oh, I
didn't really know the loss.
I didn't know the impact.
And so I wrote this song and, you know,
it ended up being like,
I wrote the song for like my daughter
and my husband at the time.
And little did I know it was
only a piece of this puzzle,
this full puzzle,
'cause like now,
- It's a page.
I have the, it's yeah,
and I have this whole full
puzzle sitting in front of me.
Well, what I think is, you never know.
And literally there's a
lyric on my new album,
in a song called
(indistinct), and it's like,
"By the way, piece by piece,
I found out my hero is me."
And it's
- Oh, what a beautiful thing.
Yeah!
Well, 'cause it's like, and
not like in a negative sense,
in like a way of like,
it's almost too much to put on someone
to do that for you.
You know, you have to do that,
like kind of yourself, piece by piece.
You have to get there yourself.
But it's so funny, 'cause
that's the, I'm the writer.
- Right!
- And I was like, I was a little off.
I was like, but I got there.
I was like, it's okay. (laughs)
- But that's, you know,
like Eric Clapton gets
the credit for this quote.
"My greatest work is my greatest work,
I just held the pen."
And so I think it's...
I think it's God kind
of doing their thing,
they're doing this thing
- You're the vessel.
the way they do.
And even you as a writer,
there's gonna be something,
if the song is timeless,
will come back to you and present itself,
and you go, I never knew it that way.
- [Kelly] Yeah, I agree, I agree.